>> SEAN: WELCOME TO "HANNITY"
ON A BUSY NEWS NIGHT.
GLAD THAT YOU ARE WITH US
TONIGHT AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONTINUES THE INTERNATIONAL TRIP
ABROAD, LOOK AT WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT HOME.
AMERICA'S ECONOMY HAS BECOME THE
ENVY OF THE WORLD.
FIRING ON ALL CYLINDERS, AND FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS WE
ARE ENERGY INDEPENDENT AND A NET
EXPORTER OF ENERGY.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS AT ITS
LOWEST POINT SINCE 1969.
WE ARE NOW SEEING RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKFORCE.
YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT.
THAT MEANS KIDS LIKE ME WERE OUT
OF TROUBLE.
AND THE PEOPLE THAT UNFAIRLY
SUFFERED THE MOST UNDER THE
OBAMA-BIDEN ECONOMY, THEY ARE
4R WILL
NOW THE SINGLE BIGGEST
BENEFICIARIES OF DONALD TRUMP'S
LOW TAXES, LESSENING OF
BURDENSOME REGULATION AND HIS
AMERICA-FIRST AGENDA.
4R
WITHOUT A DOUBT, IT IS AN
AMAZING TIME TO BEGIN AMERICAN
AND LOOK TO ADVANCE HER LIFE,
YOUR CAREER, YOUR STANDARD OF
LIVING.
BUT THAT IS NOT WHAT YOU WILL
EVER HEAR FROM THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA MOB.
INSTEAD, WE GET OBSESSIVELY
NEGATIVE COVERAGE OF THE
PRESIDENT EVERY SECOND, HOUR, OF
EVERY DAY.
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, INSULTS,
OUTRIGHT LIES LEADING THE NEWS
CYCLE.
AND FOR TWO AND HALF YEARS THE
MEDIA HAS HISTORICALLY AND
-- HIS HYSTERICALLY AND
BREATHLESSLY REPORTED LIES, A
HOAX SURROUNDING TRUMP AND
RUSSIA.
IT IS A NO SURPRISE THAT WE HAVE
A NEW RESEARCH POLL THAT SHOWS
AMERICANS NOW SEE FAKE NEWS AS A
BIGGER PROBLEM THAN TERRORISM.
THAT IS THEIR POLL.
ACCORDING TO PEW RESEARCH
CENTER, THIS COUNTRY IS MORE
WORRIED ABOUT FAKE NEWS THAN
TERRORISM, SO-CALLED CLIMATE
CHANGE, RACISM, SEXISM, EVEN
VIOLENT CRIME.
THIS IS A MAJOR POLITICAL
VICTORY FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE HAS EXPOSED THE PHONY NEWS
INDUSTRY FOR WHO THEY ARE.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY,
AND AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT HAS
SUCCESSFULLY EXPOSED AND
ABUSIVELY BIASED CORRUPT AGENDA
DRIVEN PRESS FOR WHO THEY REALLY
ARE.
WITH TWO SIMPLE WORDS.
FAKE NEWS.
NOW TRUMP HAS BRANDED THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE ACTIVELY
WORKING AS AN EXTENSION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ALL WHILE
PRETENDING TO BE JOURNALISTS,
THE BRANDING IS NOW PERMANENTLY
TATTOOED INTO THE SO-CALLED NEWS
ORGANIZATION.
AND THEY WILL FOREVER BE
REMEMBERED, THEIR LIVES, THEIR
CONSPIRACY THEORIES BY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I DON'T THINK THAT THEY CAN
NEVER RECOVER.
AND WHILE AMERICANS ARE NOW
AWARE OF THE THREAT THAT IS
POSED BY FAKE INFORMATION, BY
LIES, CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THEY STILL HAVE THE RAGE-FILLED
TRUMP-HATING MEDIA MOB THAT WILL
NEVER SLOW DOWN.
YOU THINK THEY WILL ADMIT THAT
THEY ARE WRONG?
MAKE CORRECTIONS?
TRY AND ADJUST, ADAPT, AND
LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE THAT THEY
ARE SUPPOSED TO SERVE?
DON'T COUNT ON IT.
DURING THE PRESIDENT'S IMPORTANT
TRIP TO EUROPE, THE FAKE NEWS
SMEAR
MACHINE IN FULL GEAR.
GET THIS, ACCORDING TO "THE
HILLS" MEDIA REPORTER JOE
CONCHA, THE PRESIDENT HAS
RECEIVED MOSTLY GLOWING REVIEWS
FROM THE BRITISH PRESS.
BUT HERE AT HOME, A MUCH
DIFFERENT PICTURE.
AS PER USUAL, WE HAVE NBC'S
CHIEF CONSPIRACY THEORIST RACHEL
MADDOW SETTING THE TONE FOR ALL
OF HER COLLEAGUES.
HATEFUL, BASELESS COVERAGE OF
THE PRESIDENT'S TRIP.
BY THE WAY, THE RATINGS ARE
SHOWING IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HOPE YOU HAVE ENJOYED YOUR
TRIP.
TO LONDON, MR. PRESIDENT.
BORIS DID NOT HAVE TIME FOR YOU,
ALL OF LONDON TURNED OUT TO DROP
4R THEIR DRAWERS AND MOON YOU.
AND ALL OF THE BUILDINGS IN
LONDON, THINGS TO EMBARRASSED OR
UPSET YOU WERE ON DISPLAY.
>> IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
TRUMP THOUGH, BECAUSE HE IS AN
EGOMANIAC.
AND HE SEES ALL OF THIS AS BEING
ABOUT HIM.
>> WHAT IS WRONG WITH HIM?
>> WHERE TO BEGIN.
>> I AM SERIOUS.
>> NARCISSISTIC PERSONALITY
DISORDER.
>> HE CLEARLY APPEARS LESS
CAPABLE OF US IS STAINING HIS
OWN THOUGHTS FOR LONGER THAN 4-6
SECONDS.
IT USED TO BE THAT HE CANNOT
FOLLOW ANYONE'S CONVERSATION,
NOW HE CANNOT FOLLOW HIS OWN
TRAIN OF THOUGHT.
>> SEAN: NOW TRUST ME, IF
TRUMP WERE TO CURE CANCER, THEY
WOULD STILL HATE HIM.
THANKFULLY AMERICAN SEE THE PAST
THE HATEFUL LIES, PASS THE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, AND THE
A ARMCHAIR PSYCHOLOGY SESSIONS.
EVEN
ACCORDING TO A CNN POLL, THE
AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT TRUMP
WILL WIN REELECTION.
AND MORE GOOD NEWS FOR THE
PRESIDENT, IN HIS REELECTION
CAMPAIGN, THE CHALLENGER, THE
SLEEPY, CREEPY UNCLE JOE BIDEN
FACING A MAJOR PLAGIARISM
SCANDAL YET AGAIN.
I WILL ADDRESS THIS IN PART TWO
OF MY MONOLOGUE.
FIRST JOINING US WITH MORE ON
HIS ANALYSIS OF AMERICA'S FAKE
NEWS EPIDEMIC, WE HAVE "THE
HILLS" JOE CONCHA.
GREAT COLUMN TODAY, GREAT
COMPARISON TODAY, IT IS ALL
ACCURATE.
AND THEY SEEM TO NOT BE ABLE TO
CONTROL THE RAGE OR PSYCHOSIS.
>> YEAH, AND IN THIS CASE, SEAN,
YOU HAVE ANOTHER MEDIA.
THE BRITISH MEDIA IN THIS CASE
THAT IS QUITE A JUXTAPOSITION OF
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IN TERMS OF
U.S. MEDIA.
YOU MENTIONED IT BEFORE.
MOST OF IT HAS BEEN NOT SO MUCH
POSITIVE, BUT AT LEAST OBJECTIVE
IN TERMS OF THE PRESIDENT'S
VISIT.
IT DOES NOT CONCENTRATE ON THE
SIZZLE, BUT THE STEAK.
IT CONCENTRATES ON BRITISH
MEDIA, THE PRESIDENT'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE QUEEN, HIS
RAPPORT WITH HER.
TELEVISION IS A VERY POWERFUL
MEDIUM, YOU SAW THE PICTURES,
THE OPTICS COMING OUT OF THERE.
IT WAS VERY GOOD FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
ANYBODY OBJECTIVE CAN SAY THAT.
THE SAME GOES FOR THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THERESA MAY IN
THE PRESS CONFERENCE HE HELD AND
SO ON.
WHAT WE SAW FROM THE U.S. MEDIA
BESIDES THE SOUND BITE THAT YOU
PLAYED FROM THE OPINION SIDE WAS
THE OBSESSION WITH THE TRUMP
BABY BLEND.
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE WATCHING THE
O.J. WHITE BRONCO IN 1984 ALL
OVER AGAIN.
EVERY TIME YOU TURN ON CABLE
NEWS IT WAS A MICHAEL AVENATTI
OF BLIMPS.
YOU CANNOT GET AWAY FROM THE
BLIMP.
IT WAS WHAT WAS BEING
CONCENTRATED ON.
AND THE OBSESSION WITH THE
PROTESTS.
THE PROTEST WHEN DONALD TRUMP
WENT TO BRITAIN IN 2018 WERE
INFINITELY BIGGER.
CONSIDERABLY BIGGER THAN THEY
WERE THIS TIME AROUND.
AND EVEN TODAY, DURING D-DAY,
THE 75TH ANNIVERSARY THAT OCCURS
TOMORROW, YOU STILL HAD
PROTESTERS ON A DAY WHERE GIVE
IT A REST FOR ONE DAY, GIVEN THE
SACRIFICES THAT HAVE BEEN 75
YEARS AGO IN FRANCE.
>> SEAN: LET ME ASK YOU THIS,
I BELIEVE THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
EXPOSED THEM IN A WAY THAT
NOBODY ELSE COULD.
AND IT IS BRANDED.
IT IS TATTOOED ON THEIR FOUR
HEADS.
I DO NOT SEE THE BRAND
RECOVERING, DO YOU?
>> I THINK WHEN THE PRESIDENT
LEAVES THE STAGE, WHENEVER THAT
MAY BE, IN A YEAR AND A HALF OR
IN SIX YEARS, THIS WILL BE
LIKELY '87 STOCK MARKET CRASH IN
TERMS OF RATINGS AND CLICKS
GOING AWAY, BECAUSE THE MEDIA
HAS MADE HIM THE EVIL
PROTAGONIST.
AND WHEN YOU TAKE HIM OUT OF THE
PICTURE, IT IS LIKE TAKING JR
EWING OFF OF "DALLAS," THERE IS
NO MORE SHOW.
SO UNFORTUNATELY IF THEY WANT TO
RETURN IN CREDIBILITY, I'M NOT
SAYING ALL PUBLICATIONS WERE
NEWS CHANNELS, BUT MOST OF
THEM --
>> SEAN: I WOULD ARGUE THREE
NETWORKS, POSTING
"THE WASHINGTON POST,"
"NEW YORK TIMES," LET'S START
THERE.
>> I STILL WAVE MY POM-POMS FOR
LOCAL MEDIA, WHICH STILL HAS A
LOT OF CREDIBILITY, BECAUSE WE
NEVER SEE OPINION BEING INSERTED
INTO YOUR LOCAL NEWSCAST.
>> SEAN: JOE, IT IS
INTERESTING, BECAUSE EVERY
NEWSROOM IN AMERICA GOT THE
TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION
CONSPIRACY HOAX, THEY ALL FELL
FOR IT.
AND THEY MISSED THE BIGGEST
STORIES ABOUT ABUSE OF POWER,
CORRUPTION, RIGGING HILLARY'S
INVESTIGATION, THOUGH DIRTY
DOSSIER, THE FISA APPLICATIONS,
LYING, AND PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON
A FISA COURT.
IT IS THE TALK SHOW HOST THAT DO
ALL OF THESE THINGS THAT EXPOSED
IT.
>> THE MUELLER REPORT AND WHAT
THAT EXPOSED BETWEEN NO
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
ASSOCIATES AND RUSSIA WAS A
DEATH BLOW TO THIS INDUSTRY.
I'M NOT SAYING ALL OF, AGAIN,
BUT MANY IN IT.
YOU PLAYED A CLIP OF RACHEL
MADDOW BEFORE.
SHE HAD HER LOWEST RATINGS LAST
MONTH AND A VERY BUSY NEWS
MONTH, LOWEST RATINGS SINCE
TRUMP'S INAUGURATION.
A CNN YOU SEE DOWN DOUBLE DIGITS
AGAIN LAST MONTH ON TOP OF A 26%
LOSS AND AUDIENCE THE MONTH
BEFORE THAT.
THAT WAS A WATERSHED MOMENT WHEN
THAT REPORT AND ALL OF THE